[Música]
con su amo
en 1981 el partido socialista francés
logró su primera gran victoria de la era
de posguerra cuando foami te ojo se
convirtió en el primer presidente
socialista de la quinta república
leyes de los resultados que he recibido
demuestran que el pueblo francés ha
elegido mi plaza
yo lo puse tras vencer gracias a una
alianza con el partido comunista a mí te
ojo y su campaña por el cambio social
poco después de su elección supervisó
las reformas que incluían
nacionalizaciones reducción de la semana
laboral aumento del salario mínimo y de
las prestaciones sociales políticas que
fueron populares entre la clase
trabajadora pero ante la inflación y el
creciente déficit
mateo dio un giro de 180 grados y adoptó
medidas de austeridad lo que fracturó a
los socialistas ya sus votantes y aunque
el mandatario fue reelegido en
1988 muchos consideran sus últimas
medidas como un punto decisivo para el
partido 2002 supuso otro revés para los
socialistas cuando su candidato a lionel
jospin no pasó a la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones
se vio superado por el ultraderechista
soma
asumo toda la responsabilidad de esta
derrota
en consecuencia decido retirarme de la
política de la política y la pérdida de
apoyos continuó mientras la clase obrera
francesa ser configurada por la
desindustrialización y la globalización
los socialistas se esforzaron por
responder al creciente malestar de su
base electoral con la pérdida de sus
votantes tradicionales un think tank
sugirió en 2011 que el partido se
centrará más en la población urbana con
estudios las minorías y los jóvenes al
año siguiente los socialistas volvieron
al poder con joshua olont pero su
mandato se caracterizó por unos índices
de aprobación mínimos que en algún
momento rondaron el 4% y sus impopulares
reformas laborales provocaron protestas
olont no se presentó a la reelección y
el partido vio como el apoyo de la clase
obrera seguía disminuyendo en la primera
vuelta de la encuesta de las elecciones
de 2017 el 37% de los votantes de clase
trabajado ahora apoyo a la extrema
derecha el 24 voto a la izquierda de
rowling melón show mientras que sólo el
5 de los obreros voto al candidato
socialista benoit hamon este acabó en
quinto lugar con sólo el 6% del total de
los votos de la primera vuelta ese año
la victoria de emanuel marco consolidó
la inclusión del partido socialista cuyo
colapso continua